gentlemen I had the worst taxi ride of
my life oh we're just gonna get straight
into it we never left I you know I was
um okay so I'll lay the scene for you
right so I have a shoot at 1 30 p.m okay
all right so I got to be there a little
bit early right I'm trying to get there
one one fifteen but I'm like you know if
I get there one five one ten I'll just
get a coffee somewhere nearby yeah I'll
chill out so I I schedule my taxi right
uh schedule if I'm super British
schedule so schedule it right so that I
can get there at latest 1 15. yeah give
me 15 minute buff up try and be
professional trying to be great so I
call this taxi right and it's like it's
like a Japanese kind of uber version app
and it normally takes at most 15 minutes
so I schedule taxi or whatever it is
the point is that I'm like buffering on
buffers right so I call the cab at 12
30. it's a 20 minute Journey so I have
plenty of time if it's like the maximum
I I might even get there completely far
too early right so I I get the app and
and it's and I I called the taxi and
Boom at 12 30 I have a taxi driver who's
arriving in 15 minutes yeah that's a 20
minute Journey so the taxi should arrive
at 12 45 and then I'll get there at 105.
a little bit early that's fine it's fine
okay
so I have 15 minutes so I go and I go
and brush my teeth I go and start
getting ready and I go and check my
phone 10 minutes later and he hasn't
moved it's still 15 minutes away and I
can see that he's beginning he's been
going up and down this one road and I'm
like I'm sure it's nothing I'm sure it's
fine
listen I'm sure I'm sure you know he
just got a little lost on this one road
it's a main road you know you just
couldn't get off it right it's no big
deal sure I should have canceled right
then and there I most certainly should
have and I so regret it right I had the
thought in my head of I'm sure this is
nothing right and I should have listened
to myself and realized this was a sign
of things to come so to to get to my my
where I am there's a series of like
one-way roads that are a bit confusing
and they they have to enter at this
certain point if they don't enter at the
certain point it's like it adds five to
ten minutes of [ __ ] to try and get
back to where I am right yeah so he's
coming up to it and I'm waiting outside
and if you get if he gets this turn he
can comes to me I'm ready to go of
course he [ __ ] misses it just goes
right past it even though the navigation
tells him where to go and I'm like
whatever it's fine okay it's almost like
GPS's weren't invented for a reason I
know I know I know there are a lot too
far there are a lot of time tribes in
Japan who take GPS as a suggestion yeah
um so it's whatever it's happened before
I'm not a bit it's not a big deal yeah
just circle around he'll come but it
adds five minutes right yeah so again so
we're all he's already 10 minutes later
than he's supposed to be and now it's
five minutes so what he should have been
here 15 minutes now it's 30. so and now
just about be on time
so he he finally gets here and you know
I I understand sometimes they can't find
the exact location where you tell them
to pick you up from [ __ ] didn't
even try he was like three blocks away
and then press the I'm here button so
then I had five minutes to get to him
otherwise it started it cancels it or
charges me money yeah yeah so I'm like
what the [ __ ] so I'm rushing to get to
him and then I finally get to the car
with like one minute remaining on this
timer otherwise my journey gets canceled
and I get charged money yeah and he's
not even in the [ __ ] car he's a gun
somewhere so I tell you a smoke break or
something we're walking around like
where where is this guy yeah so I'm just
sitting there and finally he comes and I
he obviously realized that he [ __ ] up
so he was around looking for me and I'm
like just waiting in the cab I'm coming
to you yeah yeah yeah yeah whatever
whatever okay it's a bit weird a little
uncomfortable and I've got a shoot to be
to and I this is a very precisely timed
thing that I can't miss everything right
we have one hour and everyone's waiting
on me it's and like the venue that we're
filming at is going to open at three so
we only have that one hour window to
film sure so
I'm like whatever it's fine I'll be on
time this is weird and so I get in the
car
and this is when I started to get
worried
he kind of just sits in the in the
driver's seat for about 30 seconds
and he goes oh where are you going
I was like what okay what are you where
am I going I'm like it's on the app and
I'm like I pull out my phone I'm like
it's on the app when I ordered you on
yeah yeah and this guy wasn't a normal
taxi driver because he didn't have in
Japan if you're a taxi driver there's
got to be a bunch of identification yeah
and stuff on the window to kind of let
you know who who's driving you and what
company they work for in case you have a
complaint or something you didn't have
any of that so it was clearly a private
hire only right so this guy only works
through this app and maybe he's new or
something or I don't know and I'm like
whatever it's fine yeah I'm like well
yeah look at the app I said use the
navigation on the App please and you're
telling him how to do his job
to be fair a lot of the taxi drivers
like to clarify that you put the right
address yeah because I've had it where
I've put it in wrong yeah and I'll
correct him and I'll be like oh actually
no it's here but yeah this didn't seem
like that but it wasn't like that at all
yeah so I'm like I'm like show him the
phone I'm like oh this navigation please
use this one right so he grabs my phone
even though he has it on an iPad right
here that is much bigger than my phone
it starts to French basically zooming in
on where I told him to go right and I'm
telling him I'm like oh oh no no that's
that's not going to help you because I'm
in like a it's in like a really weird
Alleyway yeah it's like it's not going
to help you and so he's looking at it
frantically zooming in and he's like
yeah I don't know what this is I'm like
well that's why you listen to the air
that's why there's a GPS telling you
where to go I know you know again I'm
being polite about it I'm like all right
this is whatever and be quite quiet I'm
just telling you I just kept telling him
like please use the app yeah please use
the app navigation and and so and then
he's he's trying to read the address on
the thing and it's because it's in
English I'm like I I tell him the
address yeah and so now he starts
putting it in and I'm like again I
remind him like you can just use the app
yeah just use the app like it's right
like it tells you where to go and you
put the address in but put it in wrong
oh my God I'm like no that's wrong
that's not where I'm going
this is the address oh I'm sorry I'm
trying to like kind of like talk him
through this yeah and he finally gets
the address right and then he puts it in
on his iPhone and I it was really odd
because I was trying to speak to him in
Japanese but he clearly didn't speak
much Japanese either okay uh he I think
he was Chinese right because I heard his
like iPhone telling him his stuff it was
really confusing right um and I was like
whatever well I mean we're both trying
to figure out a halfway language here to
communicate right
um and so
he finally finally starts the car and
he's put the navigation in and now I'm
going to be just on time if things go
right right yeah but he's been taking so
long to get started in this car that a
giant truck has parked in front of us
and there's a car behind us and this guy
is clearly not confident enough to get
out of this parallel park situation
um so he just kind of sits there for
five minutes okay I'm getting to the
point I'll drive [ __ ] it just give me
I'll get it I'll do it so waiting for
five minutes yeah to get out for to wait
for one of these guys to move like he
could have if he wanted to and he wanted
to be like Fast about it he could have
asked the guy in front to just move up a
little bit but I think he was a bit
nervous he seemed really nervous about
the whole thing
um and so finally the car behind us
moves
and now he has to reverse and for some
reason this is like a hard task he can't
reverse the car it's just not happening
and I'm sitting there awkwardly
listening this beep beep and we're just
not moving okay he's like looking behind
looking behind look at the screen
looking behind for about the most
awkward two minutes of my life right
where he keeps looking behind and not
moving right and then he goes ah
restarts the car I'm like what is that
what's happening what is did he
literally just do a ton and off and on
again like he restarts the car right and
then now we reverse and I'm like okay
this is weird so we start driving and a
shooting I would run about 30 seconds
and he's fiddling with something on the
iPad
so what's he doing he's looking at this
iPad non-stop all right and suddenly get
a notification on my phone your ride has
ended
what's that what did he just give up I
think he accidentally pressed end right
right and now I'm like what happens now
because he just started driving right
yeah and now I'm like uh uh
uh and so he starts driving and I'm
trying to figure out what the [ __ ] do I
do like I'm yeah I'm like I don't know
if I'm gonna be late where's he going
yeah yeah I'm like does he need so he
has to he has the navigation in his
phone right but I'm like I'm like
worried now he ended the ride on Uber
right yeah basically so I'm like what
what happens now like I didn't know what
to do and I was trying to figure out
what I said
yeah and so I I was thinking like man
what should I do should I just like let
him keep driving or should I should I
ask him to stop at some point like
because if he's because they've already
been charged yeah like the full amount
of the trip is like it's pre-paid right
yeah so I've already been charged for it
all so he has to take you there yeah but
on his thing it'll say that like he
didn't take me there so it's really like
I'm just unsure what to do because I'm
pretty sure I'm not going to get a
refund yeah yeah so I'm kind of like
okay [ __ ] it I'm sure he'll get me there
and this won't be a problem yeah I
should have got the [ __ ] out of the car
right
so right to leave my house there's like
you can go straight and it'll turn
around and there's a or there's a right
turn you can do sorry left turn you can
do right away yeah and he has to just go
straight right and of course he just
immediately turns and I'm like no no
even though the sat nav is telling him
to just go straight he just ignores it
right and I'm like oh no oh no this is
going to keep happening isn't it and I
[ __ ] you not every single turn he
ignored okay every single one and then
the writers were pulling out of my place
to go on a main road he nearly hits a
car like straight up like this car's
going really fast and he's just going
into traffic and I'm like
I'm a genuine like a fearing for my life
now this guy can't listen to the sat nav
he seems to be [ __ ] up everything
yeah and can't reverse can't reverse
nearly driving into traffic and he he
refuses refuses to listen to his own
navigation okay and it is stressing me
out because now I'm I see that every
single turn he misses two minutes adds
up right right four minutes five minutes
ten minutes he there was one point where
he just had to keep going straight and
he just decided to turn and then
realized he [ __ ] up and added on five
minutes trying to do a U-turn and I'm
like I'm gonna die like what what why
though like I don't know did he think he
was like oh I'll take this foreign
[Music]
and it seemed as if he would only take
turns
from what I noticed if they were like
clean corner turns right if you had to
go into traffic to do wide turns yeah he
wouldn't take it he would ignore it
right and I was like
should you does he have a driver's
license yeah yeah yeah kind of sounding
like he doesn't have a driver's license
running through my mind right and so
he's like zoolanders like I can only
turn around
you would only do it's like it's
literally like Zoolander he would only
do the like the if you're in America
like the right turns yeah yeah he
wouldn't do any turns that were wide and
kind of into traffic yeah I was just
making me like I'm like oh my God this
guy is like so instead of just going
straight to my destination on a map he's
doing like this right only doing like
back alleys and small turns right and at
one point he's he he realizes right that
the the ride has been ended right and so
he keeps fiddling with the iPad looking
at it but he's driving the whole time
and it's on his chair on the passenger
seat so he's it's not like he's looking
at something on the dashboard like this
he's like this
oh my God and and at multiple points we
were like in full-on moving traffic and
he was like
yeah and you know I politely asked him I
was like hey um can you look at the road
yeah because I was like this is Beth
like at one point yeah we were it was
like the traffic had backed up so we
were like we weren't near the lights we
were in the middle of the road there was
a lot of traffic and all the cars
started going and for about five seconds
he was still looking at the iPad and I'd
be like excuse me excuse me you've got
to go yeah and he was like oh oh yeah
sorry sorry sorry and it's just it was
this whole awkward mess where he just
everything he could have possibly done
wrong he did wrong everything everything
and this is and this was supposed to be
a taxi ride that went for how long it
was a 20 minute ride yeah and then taxi
ride itself not including all the [ __ ]
we've had before yeah it ends up being
15 minutes so from 20 minutes to 50
minutes because he just kept taking all
the wrong turns right yeah and we and
just walked there yeah yeah honestly
honestly and at the end of it I was just
like dreading that he was gonna be like
hey the ride ended are we gonna have to
fix this yeah and I was just like the
whole time I was like please please just
let me out of this taxi you don't keep
me in here and talking to me I was just
terrified that I was gonna have to like
have a confrontation with him right
about it I just didn't want to obviously
he's had [ __ ] to do yeah and luckily we
finally got there and he was the one
time he was going to listen to the
navigation was when it was actually
going to be less efficient for my
journey and I was like no no just keep
going straight keep going straight
please please please and it's right as
we were getting to the end and thank God
he listened and he let me out and that
was the end of it but oh my God I was so
stressed because I was late to my shoot
by 20 minutes yeah and I had to like
just fumble my way into it and get
started right away right yeah bro damn
Nightmare and I hate I hate rating
people poorly on these apps because I
because you know I'm like maybe it's
just a one-off maybe it is right maybe
this didn't sound like it was a one no
but it sounded like this guy yeah I mean
afterwards I was like no I can't I can't
there's no excuse in my mind that can
justify how much this guy [ __ ]
everything out I mean if he told me he
was an alien who just landed on Earth
yesterday I would believe it with that
amount tree and so the whole ride in the
day I was just trying to figure out like
what was that dude's deal
what was up with this like I I just know
I mean I've been in a couple of Taxi
rides where you know it's usually
because you know it was Japanese yeah
yeah yeah you know Japanese taxis
usually like an older gentleman you know
who was like very much like
anti-technology and he's like no no I've
lived in this area for 60 years I know
the road's better than any sack yeah and
then you know they clearly miss a very
simple turn yeah just from but like that
didn't seem like that yeah it seemed
like he'd I don't know if you just moved
here recently or something and he wasn't
familiar with the roads and maybe he was
scared of using them and it might have
just started but either way I knew I
mean you shouldn't be driving taxis if
you're scared of the road no there's
there's a minimum requirement to a job
of just being a taxi driver even if it
is kind of like I don't know because
it's kind of like the app is kind of
like uber but I don't know what their
requirements for [ __ ] uh clearly none
yeah I know I know that it's you know
becoming a taxi driver fan is not hard
but I mean it's not hard already
anywhere
um you live long enough
we're gonna see
I know you know not to blame the
foreigners
sometimes I felt bad for the guy because
he clearly seemed like he was
overwhelmed and I know I hate piling on
[ __ ] people who already look like
they're not handling stuff well yeah but
at the same time it's like there's a
limit yeah there's a limit to what I
think is like you should not be doing
this yeah like you and also your life is
in your his hands yeah the moment he
nearly crashed is when I was kind of
like all right this is too much now yeah
like this is like I I I I you just
you're actively like a danger yeah yeah
not only are you awful at this job from
like an efficiency standpoint you are
actively like harmful like damn we
haven't been back in Japan for a while
and it seems like you've already gone
into some like [ __ ] yeah yeah I mean
you know because sometimes uh in Japan
like more often not public transport is
quicker but depending on where you live
and how the roots are sometimes you
might have to change like three or four
times for a 30 minute Journey yeah of
course and the taxi will be one ride 15
minutes boom you're right there yeah
yeah so a lot of the time like I'll just
do that because like I don't want to
have to deal with it especially if it's
like you know 15 20 minutes away right
most of the time if you go via app
that's when you like don't [ __ ] up you
know because you can time it perfectly
yeah because the driver always follows
the app you know it's it's for the most
part for the most part you know a lot of
the times it's very common if you get in
the taxi in Japan they'll and you've
ordered it on an app they'll be a firm
they'll be like are you going here and
you say yeah and then they'll be like
cool and they they'll they I get this
ass quite a lot they'll be like do you
want me to use the navigation in the app
oh yeah yes please yeah I put it in for
a reason yeah yeah it's been like no no
no I trust yourself yeah because
sometimes the app doesn't like include
highways and highways or tolls and so
they have to manually add the toll costs
onto the price that you didn't see right
so there's a lot of there's a lot of
stuff that you might not know if you're
not in living in Japan using taxis often
yeah the taxis have some form of
etiquette and you mean it's it's a bit
different from like New York and other
places in the world yeah but I feel if
you're visiting and stuff you know the
the train system is 99.9 foolproof so oh
yeah yeah the trip might be a little bit
you know longer and more tedious
especially if you need to like change
train stations on the way but for the
most part it's fairly simple yeah if you
need to get somewhere fast and from a
location there's not a train station
taxis are like often very of course very
good at that yeah well I I feel like if
you know if if you don't know how to
like talk to a lot of taxi drivers I
actually feel like trains for sure yeah
because taxi drivers will ask you like a
lot if it's not like a train station or
if it's not like a major Monumental
that's the one thing I hate about
catching a taxi in Japan it's like when
whenever it's like I miss like I mean
you know I missed the last train yeah
taxi home right and then you know I tell
them like where I need to go and he puts
it in the sat nav and then he's like
um so do you want me to go down like
this specific route and I'm like I don't
[ __ ] know I get that as well because
like sometimes I get a taxi and they're
like um I'm thinking about going this
way do you know if I can do that or not
I'm like I'm not the [ __ ] taxi driver
I don't know my way I always just say
please use whatever navigation tool you
have I I tell them my simple trick is I
just tell them go the shortest drought
yeah yeah I'm like I don't care just
just take me home I need to be home
right because sometimes if it's not on
an app and you just call a taxi they
don't put it in the SAT like the
navigation but they'll ask you like
[ __ ] 20 questions and be like can I
go this way I'm like it's two in the
morning I'm shit-faced I don't know
where I am I just want to be home just
take me home unless it's like a very
well-known Monument or a place I
normally always just say hey can you put
in the address and then they'll pull up
the set and everything yeah
yeah and then just read it out to them